[Applause]
[Music]
welcome the fat man I'm Batman Beyond
I'm Joseph I made it I caught it as I've
welcomed the fat man beyond him Kevin
Smith I'm not Bernard holy [ __ ] man
welcome of course as always we're here
at our home at the scum and villainy
Cantina in Hollywood on Hollywood
Boulevard put your hands together to the
folks watching at home know your real as
you can see me and Marc are having a
garage sale a lot of [ __ ] designer
saucily your [ __ ] I know but wait before
we go any further we will have like open
and chitchat but [ __ ] we have so much
content tonight the good yes so much to
talk about the good and bad thing about
being a stoners sometimes you just
forget weeks but then they come back and
you're like oh [ __ ] like and I
remembered in the shower tonight
actively no just in the shower some [ __ ]
that I have not shared what that is
mind-bendingly good and for this
audience
what's up danger I'm gonna let it sit
there for a second and we'll do our open
and [ __ ] how are you I'm good man I'm
really good what you been up to well the
last couple days I've been writing about
black panther do you know why I've been
writing about Black Panther
because because we'll get into in the
news but here's a here's the interesting
thing I got and I can only talk about in
the room like I talked about it out loud
till tomorrow but uh but I got a call
from my former colleagues at
Entertainment Weekly Oh mark for those
that don't follow this [ __ ] that closely
but probably should has edited for a
number of [ __ ] major publications
across the spectrum including Hollywood
Reporter at the LA Times and
Entertainment Weekly where I became a
grown-up
and and then got lay it off almost 10
years ago is that what happened yeah
that's what happened and so they called
me like I'm always out there going he's
such a good writer and energy but
wigglies like no he's not [ __ ] you not
good enough to hang like that almost my
10-year anniversary's being laid off
they call him I said hey would you write
a cover story for us on black panther
[Music]
and ice and that's when you were like
[ __ ] you my teas boiling yeah what's the
cover story it is it's an essay about
Black Panther which will spoil the
neutral later just got nominated for
Best Picture yes which is the first
superhero movie ever to do so absolutely
and so sort of just wrapping my head
around what the last year has been and
and if there's anything [ __ ] new to
say about black man the husband said I
myself and everybody else on the
internet so yeah that was that was my
last couple of days has been sort of
wrestling with that and and I think I
found a thing I thought you found a way
to express yeah especially in context of
the Oscars and and the kind of movies I
was gonna say you must have been so
stoked when that happened you look awful
can that cash so wait were they doing a
piece regardless of it was I mean they
asked me to write it hoping then it
would have the best picture right were
you I mean look we are gonna get to the
news but we might as well [ __ ] lead
up front with it real quick Black
Panther nominated for best picture at
the Academy Awards this year ladies
gentlemen put your hands together for
the very first superhero movie nominated
for Best Picture deserving his [ __ ] a
Marvel movie they've been working their
craft so well that movie's phenomenal
Ryan Coogler crushed it everyone
involved it's fantastic I always forget
that it came out last year because it
was so long ago and stuff bad last year
took five years and we remember we
talked about it like once like do you
think they'll remember next year
and we can tell like my the the the
question that I was asking while writing
the piece was even if it doesn't get
nominated what makes this different from
every other movie that would get
nominated for an Oscar specifically what
kind of black movies get nominated for
Oscars and they are almost always about
pain they're almost always about
suffering it's 12 years of slave it's so
much it's even hidden figures is about
look at the awful [ __ ] we had to go
through to get here yeah and it's about
that kind of fetishization of that
suffering and black panthers about
[ __ ] joy it's about excellence it's
about wonder it's about so many things
but it does not ever rest in a world
that's about anguish you know and so is
that the kind of movie that the Oscars
would tend to recognize and if it hadn't
my thesis was this movies too much fun
to actually get a Best Picture
nomination because best pictures are
never [ __ ] fun my they're always like
I learned a thing in a little boy that
was rough so true so but it did and I
was really surprising and really kind of
heartening for me the idea that that
this version of a African / African
American story can get recognized which
is not about look how bad it was but
more like look how good it could have
been in an alternate history so yeah it
was it was fun that's a brilliant
approach man found a way to write about
it I earned my keep I hope what were you
watching the nominations now that I
don't have to I am never going to yeah I
saw a video of people that wound up like
getting like Spike Lee got nominated
there was video of him like freaking out
and there was a documentary crew that I
saw like getting so low you know no one
liked that old man's but it they freaked
the [ __ ] out but like I was sitting
there going well why was why were they
shooting this anyway you know what I'm
saying like that would be like me going
like they're announcing the Oscars roll
camera makers we did yoga hosers last
year
like did they know was someone like your
a front-runner so you might want to roll
some footage I guess it's adorable
though watching people freak the [ __ ]
out man like oh my god I've never been
that excited about anything shy of
coming that feels real you should roll
some [ __ ] cameras me no no I mean
we've seen you cry a lot what happened
to our camera man did it was a joke I'm
not coming really jerk-off what are you
doing well that's been the last week or
so and you know now that I'm gainfully
unemployed it's about getting more
gainfully unemployed because gemstones
redstone rapped the writers room wrapped
in the end of December so now it's a
bunch of like first date meetings you
know when you walk in and you got your
45-minute pattern it's like hey yeah so
I like long walks on the beach I'm a
Sagittarius know if you guys know that
but are you said Terrace I am yeah I'm a
Leo
we're both animal signs yeah well I I am
I'm a half animal I'm a centaur I'm king
of the beasts I'm hung like a horse yeah
you ain't lying God where were we before
that [ __ ] started out lots of lots of
meetings in general no no the question I
had a question yes now that the writers
room is closed does that mean the show
is in production yes my show runners in
Budapest cuz we're shooting in Budapest
holy [ __ ] and I think you're not gonna
go they they keep lying to me saying
they're gonna bring me to Budapest would
you go yeah I really I would you won't
get up to watch the Oscar nominations
but you'll go to Budapest if there was
like first-class treatment to watch the
Oscar nominations I might fair enough
yeah
so that's happened in the show that's
happening yeah now they're there over
say don't keep the writers room open
just in case they're like [ __ ] we need
something right something not in this
sort of modern current iteration of the
way these short shows work like it's
gonna be 10 episodes right and the idea
is to write them all and then go shoot
them all like to block shoot it's what
you would do in a production like you
just maximize the amount of time you
have with all the cast and shoot as
quick as you can make sense
classic TV used to be we started a
writers room in like May we start
shooting a show in August and it
premieres in September so you're always
racing the production train you're
always like two scripts ahead of where
they are hoping to be able to beat them
so nobody's standing around and [ __ ]
diddle in themselves waiting for a
script to show up and in that case the
writers room is always open and it's
always sort of answer questions and
there's an ebb and flow but in the short
run version the Netflix and the Toulouse
and the Amazons
they want to write it they want to close
the room and they want to go and shoot
it and if it gets picked up for season
two some of us will come back some of us
won't but it's it is a weird it's a it's
a weird way to do TV there's less
pressure but the risks are higher right
because you don't know yet what works is
the streaming model yeah like him and
you won't know what like that the great
part about TV is that it's it's an it's
a novel you're writing while you're
reading it in a way you know and you're
writing five seasons of a TV show and
over that time you see like cast members
who work and don't writers who work and
uh and you can begin to adjust even
course-correct as you go but when you're
writing everything at once you can't
course-corrected you haven't seen
anything I didn't know who we were
writing for the entire time we were
writing in the show we haven't cast
anybody yet right so it was like I hope
this chemistry is good I hope they work
well together I hope hey I hope that
guy's funny is if not these jokes are
gonna [ __ ] suck that's but that's
their job right they gotta sell the
material they do but like every every
show you watch that you love the reason
why you love it is because they've
evolved it over time you know and
they're our cast members who maybe in
the first season like blew up in the
second season became like something
really really special I'm doing this
Battlestar podcast and
and watching the first season again and
seeing who's really good at what well
nobody knew that Baltar was as funny as
Baltar could be until they saw that guy
and then they begin writing towards it
they begin giving him jokes I mean
making him this weird farce in the
middle of tragedy that it turned out
being but he wouldn't know that up top
like god I hope that guy can do this or
wouldn't even thought to ask that guy to
do this if I hadn't seen him do it so
it's it's an odd experience writing in a
vacuum but I got paid and now I'm
gainfully unemployed I learned to trust
actors more than I ever had in my career
which is weird two seconds I worked with
this amazing talent but I always felt
like you know well hey man when I wrote
the [ __ ] I'm like well I know best
because I wrote this [ __ ] but I was
working on of all things flash like it
was my second not even my second I think
it was my third episode of flash third
episode of flash and danielle Panabaker
plays killer frost and you know Caitlin
she always has the science gobbledygook
to say so she's the one that's just like
oh my god Barry if you don't do the flux
capacitor you know the entire [ __ ]
but that's even like we could all say
flux capacitor because we love that
moving [ __ ] they give her like mouths
full of ridiculous [ __ ] concepts to
make fly in a sentence that no human
being on earth would ever utter without
stopping and saying or like or breaking
it up and what not a huge [ __ ] run-on
sentence so you know I've done two
episodes at this point this is the third
episode and I always feel bad for it cuz
she's got a [ __ ] sling this horse yet
you know the [ __ ] just make it work
and you know you're like oh my gosh
she's gonna break her neck trying to
[ __ ] spit this [ __ ] out so the third
time out she had this big old speech and
you're not supposed to the director like
[ __ ] with the dialogue she the writers
King in TV and the director means
nothing and stuff but I was like I can't
I can't [ __ ] put a human being
through this one more time this feels
cruel so I said hey man don't you don't
need to say all this [ __ ] like [ __ ]
there's an easier way to say it like
don't like I trust me in my cut and the
director's cut this is all getting cut
anyway so like don't you know don't
break your neck and she goes honestly I
love doing it like it's what I do and I
was like um all right man I was like you
poor broken Stockholm Syndrome
[ __ ] I gave you a door and you
wouldn't choose it but then she showed
me why she took that [ __ ] [ __ ] and
sang it made it work where I was like
holy [ __ ] man like you shouldn't change
a word she didn't [ __ ] alter it or
cut it down like I was suggesting she
did exactly what was on the page and
[ __ ] delivered it beautifully where
you're like oh my god that's why I love
that show
like sometimes they will say
ridiculously long sentences and she
pulled it off and stuff so I learned in
that moment like you know what like they
don't need necessarily to always be told
what to do some of them are very
intuitive and now that is the case if
somebody's played that character for
like multiple seasons totally so she's
used to like look man I'm [ __ ] doing
the science gobbledygook that's why I'm
here and [ __ ] I mean an arrow in the
first season felicity was just like the
tech girl there was never gonna be a
romance between them that was never part
of the plan but when they saw those two
people together it's like oh [ __ ] hmm oh
damn if we're not here they're [ __ ]
so we might have to put that in the show
which they did yes I might want to watch
them [ __ ] is that an expression if
we're not here they're [ __ ] is that
like a penny saved is that within like
the TV community like this shirt like
look man their chemistry's so good if
we're not there they're [ __ ]
or did you just literally let that fall
out of your mouth that just kind of
happen right that is brilliant
this is [ __ ] that isn't a brilliant
analogy man like to communicate can
y'all pizza this is fun
that's pretty hot all right wait what
were we talking about gets so distracted
that made me a little hard we're not
talking about that anymore yeah thank
God
what do you been into what have I been
up to I you know what I've been up to
some [ __ ] I was I directed an episode of
the Goldbergs last week then I had a
thing on Monday night of last week I
hosted a premiere party for sci-fi show
deadly class ah which just started
airing is a wonderful [ __ ] style of
show with great performances and stuff
well [ __ ] hot I watched the show and
I was like this is where [ __ ] TV this
is where hour-long TV is now on sci-fi
like I'm about to go make a movie myself
and I felt like cowed by watching it
like Jesus Christ man like I don't know
how to do any of these things so the
show was like very impressive in one
night so I got to host me and the kid
hosted a premiere party and stuff so the
whole cast was there got to meet the
cast was really cool creators were there
and they talked about you yeah because I
went up for staffing on that show before
I got Treadstone part of my like first
dates around Hollywood right was I went
to meet on deadly class and with Rick
with Rick Remender and miles Felson Rick
is a comic book yeah
amongst many comic books but he did the
comic book as well so for him to still
be involved and not just in the produce
toriel capacity of like hey it was my
comic book like he wrote scripts and ya
know he produced and he had a guy named
miles miles felts out yeah who is he was
the one who said I know mark yeah yeah
his his wife and I when a writers
program together and and so yeah wise I
went up for staffing on the show and it
went really really well
but it took really really long and
sometimes the the one of the worst parts
about Hollywood is nothing happens as
fast as you want it to until it happens
too [ __ ] fast that you can't slow it
down yeah hurry up and wait and so I met
on that show and like
April and I went really really well and
they're like yeah we're just we got to
bring a couple more people on and we're
gonna make some decisions and we're
gonna put [ __ ] room together and do a
show I said that sounds amazing the
pilot was really strong kids killing
kids who doesn't love that right that
was one of my questions with them's like
listen I I am in my current mindset
right now where like every other [ __ ]
week there's a school shooting like a
show that's gonna go for five seasons
about children killing each other is a
bit much for me and Rick said it's a bit
much for me like I wrote the comic book
and that's what it was when I wrote it
but we can't do that show now like I
don't want to do that show now so good
good on you realize to pivot a little
bit and make something there like PS get
the [ __ ] out yeah and you're done
yeah the timing just didn't work out by
the time they were ready to open up the
writers room I had already that's what
they said they were like we want to hire
mark but he by the time we were ready to
go he was someplace out sounds like
treads to him yeah I think so but yeah
they were very cool they know they're
very good shouted you out and whatnot
but the show is produced by the Russo
brothers really yes who brought us of
course the Dre tell you what happened so
um of this year last year about endgame
infinity work I would do it slowly
i I I had a moment but I mean I was I
was standing there taking pictures of
the cast and one of the publicist
brought over said this is Anthony Russo
I look at him I [ __ ] instantly throw
my arms around him and give him the most
uncomfortably long hug he'll ever
receive in his life like the kind of hug
you give someone when they're like my
[ __ ] mother died and like you go in
and like oh yeah
and you're just not gonna let him go I
was doing that [ __ ] did you hook the leg
what's with the leg when you're hugging
somebody and like they're the right leg
comes around hooks around the knees like
I that never occurred to me but [ __ ]
like sweep the leg hook the leg baby
that's weird but wouldn't that then
thrust your pelvis and yes it would
that'd be really weird I loved your
movie I told them I said I was hugging
my said you're doing the Lord's work I
just would not let go like and you could
tell at a certain point it's like when's
this gonna stop but I told him I got to
gosh out on this is one of like
beautiful things about the job that I do
is that sometimes you get to meet people
who like [ __ ] make the [ __ ] that you
love and you don't have to just tweet at
them into the void and hope they say it
like look at my [ __ ] in the eye and be
like I I [ __ ] love you
you know until they're uncomfortable and
like goodbye and walk away but I did I
got to gush out and be like bro I've
seen that movie fifty three times like
and I don't just pop into a scene I
starting to go all the way [ __ ]
through and there's never a moment where
I'm like this is boring I'm gonna skip
ahead if I ever feel something like that
kick in suddenly something else happens
and I'm like oh [ __ ] I forgot I'm back I
was like so you guys crafted like this
[ __ ] true magic act and I said why I
know like I'm sure you hear from people
all time but how much they dig it but
this is why it's [ __ ] important to me
I was like I'm 48 man I shouldn't feel
the way I feel about your movie about
like anything except maybe like strained
pears or something like that like I'm
just old and like you guys make me feel
young you make me feel like I did like
during the happiest days of my life when
I was a kid in the eighties and [ __ ]
like you make me feel like when I saw
Raiders of the Lost Ark or [ __ ] Star
Wars or even Batman in 1989 like these
movies dial my [ __ ] clock back it's
not just like oh I enjoyed the [ __ ] out
of that like it's the closest thing to
Fountain of Youth
like it makes me feel [ __ ] young it
gives me a feeling I haven't had
since then and I said and it's a [ __ ]
double magic act because I'm in the
business and I don't make what you make
but like I know how shit's made so I
shouldn't be wowed or [ __ ] the magic
trick shouldn't work but even though I
to him in the field of magic I could
still sit in the audience and just
[ __ ] suspend the window of disbelief
and be like holy [ __ ] man how did they
get the hope to do that like you know I
just really buy into it so I was like
thank you for somebody who like to find
something that makes me happy like that
I didn't think I'd find [ __ ] like that
like you know later in life like you
know my father now I get why my father
would take me to the movies when I was a
kid I always thought it was for me cuz
he's like well the fat one doesn't like
sports so [ __ ] it you know the movies is
what he likes and [ __ ] but I think he
did it for him I think it was his way of
like a spending time with one of his
three kids but he got to dial his clock
back so I remember we sell Raiders of
the Lost Ark and he was so happy and he
was like that is a movie that that's
exactly like the movies I used to watch
when I was a kid and then he explained
cliffhangers which I had already known
about but I'm like I didn't want to cut
him off because he seemed like he was
having such a good time and [ __ ] and it
touched him and made him young again I
understand that [ __ ] now so I was
telling him like what you're doing I'm
sure like it makes people a lot of money
and [ __ ] and it's entertaining and
whatnot but it's profoundly [ __ ]
important to me and probably lots of
other [ __ ] people that you give an
opportunity to [ __ ] reconnect with
their youth and it's a [ __ ] you know
double act because it shouldn't work on
me but it [ __ ] does and he's like oh
[ __ ] well thank you what's your name
again no he's very
super [ __ ] screamin he was like you
know that's wow man I don't even know
it's a blah blah blah and I talked about
his entire body work I was just like I
said you and your brother man like
[ __ ] like the the Arrested
Development [ __ ] [ __ ] like Captain
America uh you know Winter Soldier
[ __ ] Civil War and [ __ ] I was like
how did it happen in [ __ ] how didn't how
did you go from that to that and he said
we heard that Marvel wanted to meet with
ten different people on the Captain
America sequel and we were one of the 10
so we were working on TV and we went in
and we just gave our best and then we
kept going back in they'd have us come
back in and the movie took shape over
time he's like what we pitched wasn't
what you saw was like that became that
over time so I got to ask him some [ __ ]
naturally I was like spoil endgame but I
said like all right you got to tell me
honestly like did you guys know when you
were making the movie that the snap
would be so like pop culturally
important that it would instantly enter
the lexicon that your mother would know
what the snap meant and [ __ ] like that
and he said no not at all he's like we
were not prepared and I said based on
that is did that make you go back into
endgame and do more [ __ ] because like
suddenly you realized that you guys made
a backdoor classic which sounds dirtier
than I mean it but like [ __ ] and he
said he said because they're still
working on it like Hawkeye posted a
picture the other day going we just
wrapped you know in that movie was
supposedly wrapped a while ago but he
said he that it was difficult making two
movies simultaneously like side-by-side
like the you know the with one Avengers
movie and the other so you know they've
just been going back and catching stuff
that they didn't catch and now they can
cross their T's and dot their eyes I'm
trying to think what else he said that I
could share he honestly it's not like
he's like hey man here's the [ __ ]
secret
like Thanos wasn't really thin oh no not
at all
he didn't tell me if I can anything I
guess that's all I got to share on that
but it was [ __ ] dope that I got to
talk to him for as long as I did and and
kind of just love on him and [ __ ] like
that I was like you guys don't get it
cuz you're like you're up this the ass
of these movies and spending years
making them and [ __ ] but like I'm out
there in the real world like these
movies mean something to people man and
that one was a magic act like [ __ ] is
the think about it that's the third
[ __ ] Avengers movie you know what I'm
saying like we should not have been that
impressed but they found a way to
[ __ ] make it fresh where you're like
oh my god Ben - bless you
the third is as important as the first
and [ __ ] so that was pretty that was a
fun evening for me to be able to do that
but while we're talking about the
Avengers real quick two things I want to
talk about there's the theory that I
just heard from JC right before we came
in that was online today okay the theory
is that it's a fan theory on a work
comes from a fan that the Thanos that we
met was not the real fan OHS but an
alternate reality Thanos and that
Avengers endgame is going to have the
real fan oohs who is the Thanos that we
saw in the mid credit sequence in
Avengers no did that sound far [ __ ]
fetched I mean the biggest [ __ ] use that
oh you know that guy you invested an
entire movie in no he's not the one see
your other guy remember him who says I
want to court death sure whatever [ __ ]
that and also its lucky Bob I'm sure
there was your theory Bob it's crazy to
me cause I'm like what you're
presupposing then is like man that
phantoms is nothing this Thanos is gonna
be a badass and I'm like he [ __ ]
killed half the people in the world like
what more do you want like you're
telling me that I the weak fan owes the
other half I guess so yeah that theory
that that's a yes
he takes out one half the other half and
then half of a future world as well yes
all that and a bag of chips Thanos
that was a crackpot theory that I heard
I sometimes like when the internet
series like for example there was a
theory I saw on the internet which I
hadn't thought about and I was like holy
[ __ ] I'd buy that and that could be his
people peace and [ __ ] together based on
[ __ ] they've seen the spider-man far
from home trailer robbed
I dropped my [ __ ] nut all over a lot
online watch it because Mysterio looks
like [ __ ] Mysterio and even when he
didn't have the bubble head he looked
like a completely [ __ ] Jake
Gyllenhaal oh my god like if I getting
like I was at first like the first time
you see the cloud you're like holy [ __ ]
is that gonna be Mysteria you see the
outfit but then he's got no helmet and
I'm like come on man but Gyllenhaal
looks so [ __ ] good sexy and his
performance was so like intense he's
like you don't want any of this [ __ ]
making magic and [ __ ] I was like that's
what all these movies have been missing
Jake Gyllenhaal eminently [ __ ] Jake
oh my god the Prince of Persia is back
yeah he was it was magnificent but then
they did show him with the [ __ ]
bubble helmet on while we're talking
about it real quick it occurs to me is
very syndrome like right like he's
representing that he's a good guy but
he's creating the bad guys that he's
fighting which is very true to a
Mysterio storyline from secular day
absolutely that that bird stole it from
somewhere I I I'm into it though battle
mosh yeah that's I'm not after tomorrow
it is so mush I'm way into it it looked
[ __ ] phenomenal but the theory if you
look at the trailer Peters like you know
I'm not gonna take my C doesn't say this
but his performance Tom Hollands better
actor than I am so he does it without
words but he's like I'm not gonna take
my spider-man suit and he leaves it and
he doesn't take it to Europe and so I
saw someone online going like whole
[ __ ] last movie was this little
[ __ ] [ __ ] trying to get the [ __ ]
suit and now he don't want to bring the
suit to you
[ __ ] this [ __ ] you know the internet
gets real hostile it really does
somebody had a theory which I [ __ ]
fell in love with the reason that Peter
and this is but I mean it's a theory so
I can't say [ __ ] spoilers but it
could potentially spoil something but
this person doesn't know either so they
couldn't even say spoilers the idea is
Peter don't want to bring the suit why
suit came from Tony so if this happens
after endgame maybe he's feeling a
little sad about the events of endgame
and doesn't want to bring the suit you
see what they're cooking right now I
smell it yeah I smell it
there's the the idea is something Bad's
gonna happen to Tony and that's why
Peter doesn't want to bring the suit
I've read that and I said I but I bet
you that's it
guarantee cuz I looked at that moment in
the trailer too and like the other
person on line I was like feels weird
like he spent the whole [ __ ] movie
trying to get that suit like all he
wants to be and he was just an Avenger
for chrissakes he got made an Avenger so
like why would he be fighting the suit
that would be a reason to not bring the
suit by it's pretty good right yeah yeah
I was wondering if all so far from home
took place before the Avengers funny she
mentioned that Amy Pascal one of the
bruisers on the spider-man movie she
used to run Sony she said in 2017
spider-man far from home takes place
starts moments after Avengers endgame is
over but possibly takes place before
infinity war begins she did say the
second part
was backing from the internet the second
part which would mean time travel yes
which we know is gonna figure
prominently an endgame so now it's all
[ __ ] piecing together man it's all
pointless to imagine what this [ __ ]
movie could be because it could be
everything I know that's what this
[ __ ] show is all about imagining
better versions of movies we eventually
see so I was thinking that that far from
home ended where infinity war began with
Peter and that on the bus there coming
home from the airport from London and
then that's when did you just come up
with that now yeah you didn't read that
on the internet no that's like that
other genius to just slip out of your
mouth they're so [ __ ] good together
they're if we're not here they're
[ __ ] I'm telling you I'm popularizing
that statement that's good that's a good
thought too man I don't know just making
[ __ ] up as we go
I like your version of things all right
all right so a whole new world yeah no
doubt take me on your carpet collab
while we're we got news to do and [ __ ]
like we do have news to do before we get
into the news let me give you the
content that I was talking about so we
you know we're I was away and then we
did other things but like remember I was
gone at one point you were and I went to
England and I talked about in other
places including on like Good Morning
America that I had gone to visit the
Star Wars set yet to visit yes to visit
the Star Wars set and see JJ making his
little movie and while I was there Grant
naturally they made me sign a
nondisclosure agreement so I can't say
[ __ ] much about anything except the
things I've said already
after which JJ sent me an email and said
would you please please shut the [ __ ] up
so you know the honor a friend of course
I will but while I was in England
this is [ __ ] so relevant to this show
fat man beyond I do remember the title I
met people on the crew who work on
cruise in on movies that shoot in
England ok on the star wars crew dudes
were just not just dudes ladies as one
ladies people in general yes human being
work in the in the British film industry
ok which includes not not just you know
[ __ ] Mike Lee movies but but like you
know Star Wars any show anything that
gets made of pine wouldn't you so this
is not on Star Wars time or done ok it's
always a [ __ ] lunchtime and [ __ ] but
I got to hang out with a lot of people
and and you know people are like oh [ __ ]
you'll love this so you get to find out
some [ __ ] [ __ ] that you don't ever
read about or hear about from other
players involved but you forget there's
all these below the line people were
like oh no I was there and I heard some
[ __ ] and I saw some [ __ ] and regardless
of what they did I know what happened
ooh yes I met people who worked on both
versions of Justice League isn't that
[ __ ] up yeah let me tell you the
things that I learned this is what I
heard about Justice League which I
thought was adorable and I was so mad we
didn't think of it first they called the
Justice League when Snyder was doing it
Zack Snyder when Joss Whedon came in and
take over
they called it Justice League right
it was right there how did none of us
know that's glorious really [ __ ] good
oh this is what I heard about Justice
League according to folks that worked on
it worked on both versions they saw Jim
Lee breakdown boards for all three
Justice League movies really first movie
mm-hmm was kind of what we saw fighting
Steppenwolf meet and Steppenwolf then
like the [ __ ] boom tube opened up and
they saw dark side and dark side saw
them there was a mini scuffle or not
depending on who you're talking to boom
tube closes that's the end of the
[ __ ] movie with them all knowing
there's something out there we have to
go
Justice League to was going cosmic as
they take the fight to apocalypse and
New Genesis presumably but we know
apocalypse and the Lantern Corps was
involved because do you remember that
shot of Alfred going like thank god
you're here let's hope you're not too
late and everyone was like oh that's
Superman because the S is the hope and
[ __ ] like that guy I met and talked to
worked on the set was like we had green
lights that were flashing on Jeremy
Irons to project the green glow I said
why
he goes because it was Green Lantern can
you [ __ ] imagine but then things
changed in production what was the third
movie the third movie was two ends
poorly like Empire Strikes Back war
infinity war so they go to space and get
[ __ ] defeated and dark side goes to
earth and levels it so the vision that
Batman had in Batman V Superman like you
know of the
[ __ ] scored shirt which which one was
that was a BB suit
BB yes sir yes where he saw the [ __ ]
scorched earth and I are demons
internship that was going to be the
entire third movie the heroes last stand
against Darkseid and the forces of
apocalypse holy [ __ ]
and then it went away so it went from
three movies to two to now just the one
to half a one they really I really feel
like hearing what I heard we might have
missed something
might have missed something big ya know
I mean that that version of it is a
little bit more interesting to me than
the version we got there was a vision it
was planned out they had a beep where he
saw like Jim Lee drew it out he's like
so you could see and these cats are in
special effects so they had to be able
to like what are we doing
yes so they saw the beat board like the
story kind of laid out and that that was
an epic vision but it sounds like a bit
of a panic decision right like we don't
like the way this movie's going we don't
really have faith in our particular
captain we feel like it's time to change
horses and and whether or not Zak had a
vision it seems like he did but it seems
also that Warner Brothers brass after
BBs and after what they were beginning
to see on Justice League
we're not comfortable with that version
of a division which and also you got to
remember like BVS came out and had like
the reaction it had and then one week
later they were all off to Europe to
start Justice League yeah so there was
no like hey let's hold on and let's do
this
let's wait let's rethink it or change it
sounds like they went ahead made a movie
and then decided to course-correct
yeah yeah I mean and even like listening
to that it sounds big and it sounds
interesting it also sounds bleakest [ __ ]
yeah sorry we destroyed all of the earth
I know but like that's kind of metal
like oh it's super metal but yeah I mean
I'm with you I understand
that is believe it's very medal in a
world that wanted pop yeah because
Marvel if nothing else is pop yeah oh no
we're on board for this we can sing
along to these [ __ ] melodies and
everything and what's this
everybody's mmmm and me and it's not
even like it's not even Metallica which
like you know some people I call I
there's one song of theirs that I like
and [ __ ] yeah this is more like [ __ ]
King Diamond works like you really gotta
be into like death metal - yeah yeah I
don't know though man like that that
sounded [ __ ] dope but they these cats
were like no it was real they're like
these these things are not made up these
things happen and they said that there's
so much of that movie that we never saw
which was much better that you know they
were like look I was there for it it was
it was like powerful stuff so yeah
there's I don't know now more than ever
I'm like get that [ __ ] Schneider cut
out there man like let's see what was
what was cooking I'm always curious to
see that [ __ ] I mean I might maybe be
made there's money to be made you know I
would also like to see the solo cut I
want to see the [ __ ] Miller and Lord
version of that movie yes because
clearly something exists but we will
have to suck a lot of dicks to pry those
things for you and I'm ready yeah yeah
for the greater good yeah let's do this
Lord and Miller lost that Han Solo movie
in the same year that into the
spider-verse came out which they're both
producers on correct yes
now when you win an award the producer
wins the award they they get the award
yes so the same you now for those not
tracking this sort of thing into the
spider versus won a [ __ ] ton of
animation Ward's including the Golden
Globe for Best Animated picture and it
was just nominated for Best Animated
Feature the second superhero movie ever
to be nominated for an award
well maybe not the second well what the
incredibles were they anomalous was the
first superhero movie nominated for an
Academy Award back in the bird for Best
Animated Feature there's never been a
superhero movie like Black Panther
nominated for Best Picture
no Birdman don't count Birdman does not
count and the reason why they expanded
the field from five movies which it had
been for like 80 years to no no no it
was ten about four years ago that's they
opened it because the Dark Knight did
not get nominated and they realize oh
hey maybe if we nominate movies that
people [ __ ] give a [ __ ] about they
would watch the Oscars and everybody
give a [ __ ] about the [ __ ] dark night
we gave that dude an Oscar we gave a
Fletcher an Oscar for it and the year
after they broadened the field to ten
hoping to be able to pull in like and
yes if this year is eight I think they
can do as many as ten but they don't
have to do ten whereas you have to do
five for actress actor director all of
that [ __ ] I couldn't find two more
movies that they liked look I don't want
to [ __ ] let's just be happy they
nominated Black Panther and [ __ ] move
on but yes they did and that's cool
thing but they also nominated into the
spider-verse which is an amazing comic
book movie Oh superhero movie not just a
wonderful spider-man film but like for
my money you know Avengers infinity Wars
my favorite movie of the year
spider-verse stand shoulder to shoulder
with it and on various days can probably
flip positions with it and you know it's
cartoon for Christ's sakes and still
it's that [ __ ] powerful why did I
bring it up oh because the the boys lost
the solo job which I'm sure [ __ ]
didn't tickle right like you know if
we've moved on and [ __ ] it worked out
and as much as the Ron Howard one came
out and didn't light the world on fire
so the boys didn't look as bad or
whatever but there was probably a
corridor in there where they were like I
can't believe we got [ __ ] fired from
a Star Wars movie this is how did we
[ __ ] survive this [ __ ] cut to there
we gonna win an Academy Award for best
animated films yes they will that's
divine justice right there man that's
nice that's the universe [ __ ] right
in itself and that movie was made with a
personal touch you could feel the
humanity at work behind that film that
is about you know some sometimes inhuman
characters and they've been working on
that movie for years is that right years
and years and years interview with Jake
Johnson who is the voice of Peter B
Parker oh he was so good said that he
had been going to various recording
booths for the last two or three years
just recording lines like what are we
doing today
I'll just say this a bunch of times all
right now would you say that bunch of
times do you say goober as many times as
you can say goober but yeah like those
things I mean listening to Moser talked
about the the length of time it takes to
make an animated movie it's for five
years sometimes yeah and so they were
hired and fired on solo in the amount of
time it took them to make into the
spider-verse it's it's got to feel good
for those cats
yeah like wow this'll work this'll do
nicely that'll do Pig spider pig
spider-ham so there it is man I forgot
to share that stuff I heard about
Justice League
nice job could have seen a couple
different flicks might have been amazing
you're like a roving reporter send you
out into the world bring back some good
[ __ ] that's why I never get hired to do
anything anymore
cuz like oh here he comes mr. big mouth
everybody be quiet and [ __ ] alright we
got news we have some news [ __ ] a man
mr. mark barnard has previously
mentioned is a man that has worked in
the media for quite some time he's a
newsie a news out he's got a nose for
news and so mark barnard went and found
all the news on the internet and he's
gonna tell you what it is right now give
it up for news hound mr. mark bernard
and take as their captain daddy did you
see that new glass picture I did not ah
somebody over there hey how did he how
many show hands how many people last put
your hands together Wow
Wow that's how many people did not see
glass but your antidote and yet the
movie was number on it movie was morning
William buck did you guys not see it
like on principle was it some kind of
like walk out you're like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
you know I saw it you went I did all
right well let's start with this
did you like unbreakable I like to break
up a lot actually did I I loved
unbreakable up until literally the last
minute of the movie Scooby Doo ending oh
not even Scooby Doo ending it's a
[ __ ] freeze-frame chips ending where
all of a sudden he's like David I'm your
arch-nemesis and then Bruce Willis turns
around that freezes and it's like he
called the cops
credits Oh like what kind of superhero
story is this [ __ ] batshit so I it
always felt like they had tested an
ending that got cut or some such [ __ ] I
don't know what happened there
but I love that movie but the ending is
insane just the last minute and
saint-like really the last 30 seconds if
you walk out before that freeze frame
what a [ __ ] killer moving you'll
wonder what happened the whole time
you'll assume that they probably had a
big battle not that one guy tattled on
the other guy so I love that movie okay
did you see slit eye this is no [ __ ]
besmirching on the movie I started
watching it and fell asleep watching it
just because I was tires not like the
movie wasn't interesting but I never got
back to it but I enjoyed what I did see
but not enough to continue watching the
movie and that was like two years ago so
but that's not a judgment I've just been
kind of busy and I do look forward to
watching it I said to myself now you've
seen one and a half of the M night
Shyamalan trilogy you need to watch one
and a half more there you go so that's
why I stand where do we stand on split
I'm it split split wins the award for
most acting because McAvoy is just like
if there's a piece of scenery he [ __ ]
choose it and over masticates that [ __ ]
he's really interesting the movie itself
kind of doesn't really stitch together
but it almost doesn't matter okay
because it's a McAvoy showpiece and he's
actually phenomenal in it glass
it's as if M night Shyamalan who I think
is is one of the best conjures of mood
yes who works in movies yes what's your
name a pen cuz you when you watch a
movie you know it feels like an M night
movie it feels like this dread just
hanging over every scene yes it feels
like everything has portent and grimness
and oh [ __ ] that mean something were the
colors the colors are telling me
something but it seems like he's only
ever read one comic book hahaha so for
that dude who's makes a comic book movie
and he read that comic but 19 years ago
more than that now but more than that
now I think you're onto something you
know like there's there's I'm gonna ruin
a connected scene in this movie alright
spoilers folks spoiler cover here you
haven't seen it you're not gonna it's
clear that you weren't gonna anyway but
like there's this big fight between the
Horde played by a James McAvoy and the
Horde is these multiple personalities
he's Muslim personalities but inside
that is the beast and the Beast is the
[ __ ] like they're super strong one is
climbing walls there's like weird veins
where McAvoy doesn't have weird veins
and David Dunn you know the overseer the
[ __ ] security guard it wears that
poncho and besides wait wait wait the
overseer vo verse is that a new lead
that wasn't in unbreakable yeah that's
that's his like public moniker like the
public is like you need a nickname buddy
you're gonna be like the overseer who
who said that to him that well cuz his
son yeah it's like searching your net
it's like here's what they're calling
you now did this is the son older now
yes same kid same kid for unbreakable
are you [ __ ] made nineteen years later
come on man let's [ __ ] anybody that
would say anything bad about M night
Shyamalan
that's a cool [ __ ] thing man yeah I
mean
but so here's what happens at the end
yeah there's this big face-off not so
much a face-off words this one dude with
no shirt on and another dude with a
poncho on standing across like a quad
like barking at each other and then Sam
Jackson's mom who was played by an
actress who's 10 years younger than Sam
Jackson but unlike the shittiest old age
makeup says who no no it's not a limited
series
it's an origin story those two things
are not mutually exclusive
you could have an origin stories limited
series and who gives a [ __ ] what you
call it because all of your comic book
terminology doesn't mean dick because
this is the most boring fight scene I've
ever seen and if it was a comic book I
would want my money back put that on a
poster which they would so yeah it it's
really really interesting until about
the halfway mark in which Sam Jackson
says the word you know it's like a comic
book and other people are like you might
be right it is like a comic book and
then everybody stops talking about comic
books and nobody's read a comic book and
then it's just like IM hae in
unbreakable
yeah it was at a time when we did not
have the cultural lexicon of comic book
storytelling that we yes be giving
credit where credit's due
he told a comic book movie story at a
time when you nobody was who has maybe
got an x-men you had gotten blade maybe
x2 was on the horizon but we were not
steeped in comic book storytelling the
way we are now so for him to not
understand fundamentally what an
audience wants from a comic book movie
or a movie is uh is a little criminal
what [ __ ] shade man I'm just so sad I
[ __ ] like so yeah it's number one of
the box office glass what is glass
that's right 47 million dollars yeah so
obviously he was right he does know what
was Rwanda comic book movie yeah but
here's the thing that I was really
impressed by which was not the movie but
that
[Applause]
he's so glad we're friends you don't
review my movies man
he self-financed it the 22 million
dollar budget came out of his own pocket
yeah and and so most of this money gets
to go back to him
good for em which like whatever you
believe bet on yourself
and if you believe in yourself enough
and you believe that an audience is
there for you then power to him he had
an output deal with blond mouse right
Jason they did split and then this was
the last and I think that's been their
deal for all him I think he's financed
all of his movies that went to plum
house but this one will i mean look they
all did well I'm sure he made money from
wasn't grandparents the visit visit I'm
sure he made [ __ ] money from that
alone but he's gonna walk away he's like
that's George Lucas smart it's not like
you know that's not without precedent
[ __ ] Lucas owned his [ __ ] as well yeah
I mean hey financed his [ __ ] whatever
else I may say about that movie
whatever else I'm gonna say about that
guy he's a hell of a [ __ ] businessman
I can now make whatever movies wants to
make for the rest of his life right and
so he wins to be fair that was always
the case though he could make movies
like well there was there was beat there
where there was but he could have always
chosen not to do their [ __ ] or big [ __ ]
and just went quiet again I mean like
the dude which he did he's clever writer
ran to visit the visit is a quiet movie
it's a small movie he did a nice rebuild
I'm happy for him man cuz he did kind of
like there was a moment there where
everyone was like [ __ ] yeah like the
whole [ __ ] world turned on him yes
like come on man sixth sense is an
amazing movie it's the trees that's it
he got killed by Mark Wahlberg what no
you guys I think it's the trees yeah I
was really kind of pushing it a little
too far so how do your mother for me
your houseplants gonna kill you
yep I mean well I guess it kind of
started with the village - right
the village lady in the water after
Earth Last Airbender that's when [ __ ]
went really bad but before last
airbender like I think the village is
where people started to turn on him and
[ __ ] and then the one the water that was
next and that's when he wrote like the
writer is gonna save the world then
people were like come on right then
there was something else after that
happening the happening having and then
after earth was his Will Smith
Scientology movie oh all right so he
took some beatings man like I mean let
him have [ __ ] glass like Jesus
I forgot that he had a Will Smith movie
that nobody gave a [ __ ] about it takes
work to get people not give a [ __ ] about
Will Smith true I had one Jersey girl he
plays a bit part nobody gave a [ __ ]
about that but he was right on the
poster for this and his kid yes yeah
well that might have been the problem
but what else do you do and then what
was the devil did you say devil he
produced the devil I want to do right
that's right there were a few movies
that he was like there was Luke the
Sonic he was like I put my name on this
[ __ ] and pretty someone about an
elevator or did the devil take place
it wasn't devil later that's why the
movie didn't connect all right so then
so he had so and then of course last
airbender which number one I know people
love that [ __ ] cartoon we do yeah so
so for him to not do the cartoon justice
was that was it created not only was
there a bunch of people like I just
don't like it as a movie but they're a
bunch of people were like you [ __ ]
aborted the last airbender he was a [ __ ]
like he took a lot of Hell for he did a
lot of Hell forward especially given
that the cartoon is set in sort of this
Asian mystical Kingdom there yes and the
leads of his Airbender movie were all
white kids except for the bad guy which
he made an Indian kid and it's like come
on
like you have to try and [ __ ] up that
bag right any day clearly he went for it
but now he's at a place where he's just
like if I could I could do this my money
I win [ __ ] everybody
I didn't I knew about the ending to
split cuz that was where they introduced
that right it tied in and [ __ ] like that
I'd seen that online so it was the holy
she had David done his back and stuff so
when they announced this movie I was
like you know what [ __ ] good for him
that's a cool idea tie it together I
remember back then when he started that
movie he was like this is just the
beginning like it meant to be something
bigger and then he went on to bigger
things to be fair after unbreakable is
what signs yes and that movie was
[ __ ] gigantic and stuff and then he
was off in other places but it's nice
that he got to circle back he got to bet
on himself and it [ __ ] panned out and
stuff good for him
do you think it like so if it did how
much this weekend the projections were
at 60 and then they dropped to 50 and
then they made 47 what yeah so like they
started that I'm starting higher and I
think word-of-mouth did not help then
here's such a little bit I really
couldn't even give this 47 million like
I made 47 but they were hoping for 16
then they were gonna settle for 50 but
they got [ __ ] with 47 I mean less what
is your impression for you've seen it
next week is the drop off steep is it a
satisfying experience well people be
like you got to go see this except for
the last act on a football field that's
pretty amazing
I don't think word of mouth is
particularly strong on this one so I
think it drops off pretty decently but
there's not a ton of competition in like
middle of January I don't even know what
the [ __ ] is opening up next week I will
go see spider-verse again for town
number five I'm wondering [ __ ] get my
hand phone I saw twice in the theaters
but I've seen it three times since on
the Oscar screener that I guess son of a
[ __ ]
oh no I don't even want to watch history
and I want to give them my money my
favorite part of that movie at this
point though you know it's unfair so my
favorite one of my favorite parts is the
opening with Chris Pine being spider-man
and it's not like I love everything
about
like the you know him winking and like
I'm spider-man but it's the moment where
he's talking to miles
it gives me [ __ ] chills when just
thinking about worries it's like you
have to wear a mask you can't know but
you can't trust anybody he's got
everybody in his pocket like that is
that was like the only time I've ever
seen something where I'm like oh that
makes sense that you would dress this
[ __ ] stupid because your because your
till Ike you if they know who you are
they can get to you like it really
impacted in a big battle is the delivery
it was the setting it was the idea of
those words jumbled together but for
some reason I think that he was so
panicked and communicating to the kid
like there's a reason behind this you'd
get a mask and you hide yourself because
of this way I [ __ ] loved that moment
like I think I'll spend the rest of my
life trying to replicate the feeling I
had and watching that moment if I ever
do comic books because it was so it had
such gravitas while being about
something so ridiculous there's a man in
a silly mask that's telling this kid
like you got to put on one of these and
it's so [ __ ] impactful so
dramatically acted that you buy it
instantly that you're like oh my god
this is [ __ ] the most important thing
anyone's ever said I mean I've been
familiar with this character my own
[ __ ] life but having that [ __ ] one
beat took my appreciation for the
character and and everything they did in
that movie and the idea of masked
Avengers in general to like a different
level like you know I don't know that
was always part of the DNA like hide
your identity to protect others and [ __ ]
like that but it was so well [ __ ]
spoken and that's the thing he's most
concerned about that's what he wanted to
important that's what makes me like cry
like he wanted to impart that like
that's the he knows that character knows
he's gonna [ __ ] die spoilers he knows
he's gonna [ __ ] die in that moment so
he imparts the most important piece of
information which is like you have to
hide your identity and with good reason
like Oh [ __ ] love it what's your
favorite part I've seen enough four
times and I cry at the exact same
[ __ ] moment and it's what what up
danger it's it's when he dives off that
bill
yes it's that whole sequence from your
dad outside the door and like listen
miles like you're special there's a
spark in you and the minute you decide
what you're gonna do you're gonna be
great and made it with his uncle saying
like you're the best of us like you you
you you're on your way just keep trying
but just they like the reflection and
the Spider Man mirror when his face
which you saw earlier its face was too
short for this photo man then the second
time his face is right up there in the
middle of it I even notice that there's
so many little tiny things and just the
the exhilaration of like I am who I'm
supposed to be and just the music and it
swells right I love the moment that also
chokes me up is when they go to Aunt
May's house computers like I'm not ready
for this anos and she comes out and
she's like Peter oh it's [ __ ] kills
me there's a lot to love in that movie
all of it is lovable but there's a lot
that makes you [ __ ] emotional even
the kingpins [ __ ] the [ __ ] with this
family like that's why it worked so well
for me he's not just like a
piece-of-shit villain he is but like
there's this weird human string that
runs to that story that makes it more
impactful oh and there's the beat I mean
we're talking about the parts of me we
love about yeah if you guys haven't seen
it just strap in know when it's at the
very tail end of the movie and peter is
in the costume and like mouth shows up
like just [ __ ] ready to rumble
and he goes how [ __ ] you did it oh I
love you I'm so proud of you like to a
kid he met like three days ago just I
love you and then it goes wait kids even
he had an arc and you know it's really
about miles but Peter gets an arc as
well totally yeah man it's it's
beautiful it's breathtaking and it's
definitely gonna win Best Animated Film
and if it doesn't we're I it it
definitely wins yes oh my god it will
win but here's what a nice what a Black
Panther mmm-hmm spider-man into the
spider verse yes
what a nice
farewell of sorts for Stan yeah Stanley
Steve Ditko right now Jack Kirby these
are you know we people making these
movies are building on the incredible
imaginations and talents of dudes that
you know aren't with us anymore and Stan
was just with us right up until you know
almost the same that right when
spider-verse came out and has one of the
most poignant [ __ ] cameos you'll ever
see that if he had been alive it still
would have made you cry that's another
moment in the movie that always [ __ ]
chokes me yeah but when he's just like
you know we were friends you know like
oh my god [ __ ] destroys me so to see
these movies recognized by you know at
the end of the day it's like the world
stage but their movies who gives a [ __ ]
but it means something right like you've
watched the reaction of Spike Lee who's
been a professional filmmaker for longer
than me 35 40 years at this point made
some of the greatest [ __ ] works of
American cinema get reduced to the
excitement of a child to be acknowledged
by his peers you know it'd be like oh my
god finally you know [ __ ] he gets
acknowledged you gotta feel the same way
about this material this is stuff that
when these cats were cobbling it
together decades back they weren't
thinking like you know one day this
shit'll get respected stan would talk
about being embarrassed about being a
comic writer and he wouldn't want to
tell people and [ __ ] like that for a
while and it wasn't until he started
meeting people who were like yeah you do
that [ __ ] love those comic books and
[ __ ] and he realized that they played a
role in stuff to watch it and now reach
a point where Black Panther gets
nominated for Best Picture and into the
Spider versus won a bunch of awards and
it's probably gonna win Best Animated
you know best Oscar for what is it
called Best Animated Feature do you know
it's not even like Best Actress or
something like that somebody pointed
that the other day a breast actor it's
best performing a leading role the best
female performing a legal role or
something like that yeah on a ferris
point of the the other day we were doing
spot cast and she was like they don't do
that it's not
actors and I looked I was like holy [ __ ]
how did on a ferris know some [ __ ] I
didn't like [ __ ] she is she's super
smart Nate's still trying to get a job
alright so wait a second hats off to our
boys man our comic book legends who they
may not be here but they're certainly
there works getting acknowledged and
their name start now writ large and the
stars give it up for Stan and Stephen
Jack alright so uh so so they're making
another Ghostbusters movie yes this was
exciting wonderful [ __ ] news that we
got last week well you guys got last
week I heard shut up I heard a long time
ago Jason Reitman was over the house and
did an episode SModcast a couple weeks
back and before we did the show we were
sitting around talking because Jason had
a bit of a rough year he had two movies
came out and neither of them like you
know if I can set the world on fire and
stuff and they're both really well done
movies but you know nothing about his
work change if anything he got better at
his job but the response hasn't been the
same as it was earlier in his career and
I'm like oh I know a thing or two about
that like you know so let me tell you
what it feels like when people stop
thinking you're impressive and [ __ ] so
we had this like kind of conversation
where you know he was at one point I was
like you know what thanks man it helps
because there's not a lot of people he
can talk to about this which is really
nice way of saying like well you're a
loser too so but he was so sweet during
this whole conversation and then said
like but I know what I'm gonna do next
cuz I was like now man now you should
just like [ __ ] pick something that
like makes you happy and [ __ ] like I
goes I got something I know what I
wanted to do next I said what is it and
he goes gran do a Ghostbusters movie I
was like holy [ __ ] man I was like I was
sitting here counseling you and your
break the glass plan as Ghostbusters
three [ __ ] me in the mouth
congratulations that's awesome he goes
no I never wanted to do this man he's
going all the interviews in the
beginning I said I'm not going to go
near ghostbusters his dad directed
Ghostbusters
- so he's like I was never gonna go near
that but I have a take on it like and
you know I feel like we talked to the
studio studio was into it they kept it
quiet and he was leaving the next day to
shoot that teaser so like we finished
the podcast he went to sleep he woke up
and they went to shoot that [ __ ]
teaser so he was like don't say anything
so I kept it quiet and [ __ ] so he better
put me in the [ __ ] movie but I
thought it was adorable he announced it
with a tweet that was like dad finally
gave me the keys to the car and it had
the ecto-1 car there so that was really
really sweet I think that blue eye I
mean look I'm not even saying I think
that movies he told me some [ __ ] and to
be fair he did not give it up freely I
had to drag [ __ ] out of him and I had to
trick some [ __ ] out of him but he told
me some [ __ ] which made me go like
alright now I just need to stay alive
until 2020 because this movie is
definitely worth seeing definitely gonna
give people based on the literally told
me again I don't want to [ __ ] make it
seem like I know a big bunch of [ __ ] but
definitely going to be a Ghostbusters
movie that makes lots of folks happy I
have to imagine that you don't make at
this point a Ghostbusters movie if you
cannot get Bill Murray to come back cuz
obviously if you can't do that then
what's the [ __ ] point I would agree
with you on that that's for sure I hope
he hope that happens
but I also I mean we were talking about
this before the show like there are some
movies that are perfect and there are
some movies that like any subsequent
attempts to rekindle recapture that
perfection will only be less than you
want it to be less than you need it to
be will invariably stray from the mark
we have never had a good Ghostbusters
sequel what do you mean you didn't like
- I don't really like - I didn't really
like the lady Ghostbusters not because
they were ladies just it wasn't a great
movie yeah yeah that's true man lots of
good to be the Murray bait that they
need I don't know I'm an adjacent
himself has got like huge credibility's
made movies with huge actors and he can
make a good movie i buy that but like is
it ever going to be what we want it to
be is it ever gonna be as good for us as
what it'll be Beverly Hills Cop - at
best because you just won the new one
yeah like you just can't capture that
awesomeness from the first time out no I
think we already had Beverly Hills Cop -
and that was ghostbusters - I think
they're I think you're Beverly Hills Cop
analogy falls apart here I don't think
it follows - I think there's a good
chance that may get Beverly Hills Cop
before no the although that would be
amazing
I think what we get here is you had a
kid who was on set for those movies and
is in - and he's an imaginative kids
begin with he's been nominated for
writing awards and stuff made a bunch of
movies all [ __ ] stand tall nothing no
[ __ ] clunkers in the bunch and [ __ ]
entrusting him with characters that are
beloved there's been a dry run at
another Ghostbusters movie prior to this
so if you want to be cynical about it
you could look at what worked or did not
work about that run I think I think we
may have something here I hope I'm wrong
I think it's gonna be special hope I'm
wrong I mean I like
he's right like cuz I did go back and
look at interviews he he was never out
there gone and one day I'm gonna bust
ghosts like my dad like he wanted no
part of that [ __ ] like you know not not
that he was like [ __ ] that and [ __ ] that
he loves his father but like he wanted
to be his own filmmaker for him to step
that close to I mean [ __ ] close to step
into the [ __ ] spotlight with that I
don't think he doesn't unless he knows
he has like the full house if not the
[ __ ] straight flush if not the royal
flush like that guy is is I'm not saying
he's like your strategic he's just smart
though I just don't think he would enter
into it lightly
I bet should we get something fantastic
yeah that's my bad
sweet Rick Moranis I don't know I didn't
ask about that but get I would be
amazing yeah I mean come on if he could
pull [ __ ] Rick Moranis out of
retirement now we're just speculating
and people gonna write articles [ __ ]
Kevin Smith says Rick Moranis is coming
out of retirement it's not [ __ ] true
at all but Kevin Smith says that movie
is gonna be [ __ ] amazing based on
limited [ __ ] that he told me I was like
oh well that comic book calm Kevin Smith
says it's gonna be amazing I didn't cry
if that means anything but it came
buckets
let's just say I ain't afraid of no
ghosts and leave it at that
what do we got next Mission Impossible
they're making two more of these yeah
they won't [ __ ] stop making these
videos hospitals the last one was
insanely satisfying you see I did
[ __ ] great like I watched you know
grant was like 6:00 in the morning and I
watched on iTunes blazed but I was like
this is [ __ ] fantastic I was like did
he just load his arms but it was good
like it was a legit wonderful movie
Chris McQuarrie did those McQuarrie he's
gonna next to to do the next two
probably before I guess they want to get
him in before Tom Cruise can't run
anymore listen you're the [ __ ]
franchise and if you can't sprint
we got no movies it's true it's like it
should be starring Tom Cruise and Tom
Cruise's running arms yeah so yeah he's
doing back to back to back
I backed that play is lame is crisp
quarry doing it yes he does the last one
he did last two he we gonna ride him yep
he's the one before this one yep I
remember that one as much is that the
one went Cruz hanging onto a plane yes
rogue nation
rogue nation that jeremy renner in it
yeah oddly enough even though I'm saying
things that were in it I don't remember
that movie that much but I do remember
the one I just saw which I don't
remember the name fallout fallout yeah
other names really that impossible yeah
re I really [ __ ] enjoyed it though so
if those cats are back I'm gonna make it
two back-to-back do you think it's cuz
of his age I never thought of that but
you're right Tom Cruise is like 108 but
now I think Tom Cruise got to be fifty
something he's 56 I think yeah so I mean
it makes more sense rather than make one
of these let's see how it does and then
oh three years from now let's pull him
out of the [ __ ] wheelchair I might as
well make two of them right now I mean
he's got that sweet feet and juice
making him young and keeping him alive
but like
till [ __ ] ride is nuts man nobody
jumped on a couch in a long time [ __ ]
makeup first many baby Scientologists
can you squeeze to get enough feet juice
to stay young forever I'm ringing the
essence this levels are strong Xenu
approves I'm I'm all for it man
they don't have a lot of they don't have
a bad guy for these movies though well
they have they had one guy for who
carried over from the last one yeah and
they kind of got rid of him pretty
quickly yeah but like the bad guy is
Darth Vader mask commuting it's like I
got a sprint man [ __ ] traffic is my
bad guy it's true do you I mean I got to
be careful with these movies is everyone
every time he does one he ups the ante
like the last one he jumps out of a
[ __ ] plane mm-hmm and they stay with
him all the way down and I thought it
was a CG shot when I saw the movie I was
like ah they must have put his face in
there but then I read an article with
like that's Tom Cruise and I'm like come
on
did anybody has no one told this fool we
have CG they get him to do the craziest
[ __ ] I think it's cuz they're like don't
tell him we could do it with a computer
let's see if he'll do it yeah yeah hold
onto the plane oh my god he's doing it
sure is some risky business Tom Locke
what's he gonna do next next movie
they're gonna be like cruise fights a
shark
he's gonna part mechanic Wiley Curtis
fire him in the space we should have bus
that's the Qaeda he lives life like he
knows something we don't you know what
I'm saying
maybe there's like yeah yeah you just
like they can't kill me I'm ready for
that I did the only my only downside for
this is sounds like he's gonna be busy
then and I look forward to them bringing
him into the comic book world like I
think he's ripe for a Marvel takeover
mmm you know what I'm saying like he's
got this franchise which is huge for him
but like you're not getting any younger
and it's you know those movies they can
add life to him of [ __ ] career I mean
maybe he's waiting for like the Robert
Redford Zone of like listen I just had
another like 10 years I'm like some evil
general guy could you imagine if they
made him a bad guy in a movie he's so
[ __ ] good it's weird though like I'm
wasted I'm still in them still a Tom
Cruise like buyer I'd buy that product
like Apple and [ __ ] what do I wear
vans like as a product I back Tom Cruise
my kid not at all don't care oh my god
when I'm like you want to watch this Tom
Cruise in she goes no and I'm like
what's wrong with your generation who's
mother [ __ ] danced in his underwear I
think he wouldn't he would be a really
good striker from when they rebooted the
x-men overhead Marvel no [ __ ] that make
him Wolverine he's older than they one
they just released I'll give a [ __ ] dude
Tom Cruise's Wolverine makes a billion
dollars yes with closets what if they
made him they couldn't make him
Professor X then he's good for like 10
20 years of the role did you shave that
head that's what would make people go
they're like have you ever seen Tom
Cruise bald [ __ ]
well you will now what if what if what
if them yeah make him like Lennon
Grossman from Tropic Thunder as
Professor X that's right he did you got
him to Bob Peck
yeah that doesn't look good on Oh make
this [ __ ] mr. fantastic Reed
Richards Tom Cruise is the perfect
[ __ ] age and he's charming his [ __ ]
thank you who
Krasinski and Emily Blunt I like that
too but I like my Tom Cruise idea better
I'll take Tom Cruise and Emily Blunt
I'll meet you halfway and Krasinski can
be the Human Torch so he gets to watch
his wife make out with Tom Cruise
so he's the human [ __ ] all right wait a
second I think we're on to something
here man Tom Cruise is mr. fantastic is
a good [ __ ] idea all right let's do
it
okay thank God we're in charge of
Hollywood oh [ __ ] we're not [ __ ] all
right why are we talking about
Oh Mission Impossible is impossible I'm
all for it it's crazy these movies
should stop but they're finding a new
ground I'm surprised that they haven't
done a TV show yet because you know it
was a TV show
it started as one why break off he's
like no I bet you that's him he's like
I'm letting this be a TV show this is
mine mine but you could do both though
yeah but then you dilute potentially the
franchise and they just found a way to
make these movies like they were kind of
trending down and then also now they're
trending up boxes throw them off
buildings and [ __ ] like will we kill Tom
Cruise this time it's true it's like is
he gonna die come and see all right what
next that's it that's all the news we
got yeah ladies and gentlemen we have
made it through the news give it up for
the news all right now we come to that
other part of the show ladies and
gentlemen
the part of the show where we open up
the room to QA the floor to you guys man
JC is out there he's got microphones
he's gonna
approach people that put their hands up
and he's gonna let you come up and ask
questions at our special little spot
here we got a bunch of stuff to give
away including did Deacon drop off
tickets what are they what kind we've
got how many 1 2 4 6 8 10 10 thank you
to ten five sets of two tickets apiece
to screen X passes to go see movies on
screen X screen X is the screen that is
very [ __ ] big it's like two hundred
eighty degrees and it wraps all the
[ __ ] way around so they show you more
movie than you normally see and I saw
Black Panther and screen X and they
worked with Marvel and they generated
new visual data to wrap around so when
you like pushed into a Conda suddenly
Wakana is like this [ __ ] big oh [ __ ]
yeah it's pretty badass nice alright so
this you ask a question we're doing five
questions you ask a question you ask a
good question that both me and Marc can
answer that starts conversation isn't
just some [ __ ] like you know again amen
Marc tell us again how much you hated
glass then you win not just some screen
X passes but some other [ __ ] thanks to
the good folks at sci-fi some folks are
gonna walk away with deadly class gear
man Kings Dominion shirt that's right
and this is a shirt that features the
character the very young charismatic
cast and that's not all too good folks
and famous brands have sent little
[ __ ] pipes we'd spoon pipes man
there's buddy Christ one and there's a
Jay and Bob Bluntman and chronic one and
there's a movies one so you ask the
right questions you're gonna walk away
with a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] we also
have oh [ __ ] for the captain
question whoever kicks us with the best
one holy Christ this is a Star Wars
icons Han Solo book from the good folks
at inside edition's they make amazing
[ __ ] books discover the incredible of
the story behind the creation and legacy
of one of Star Wars most beloved
characters with star wars icons : han
Solo
this thing is so [ __ ] thorough they
got Crimson Jack the [ __ ] rabbit from
the comic book shut the [ __ ] up that's
nuts
this book could kill a human being it's
so [ __ ] heavy man and so this is
gonna be for whom I think maybe the best
question do you think the best question
yeah so what they walk away with just
the prize for asking and then a double
prize for that
no no what's your idea I don't have one
and I just you know like most Americans
I want to Ma kuber's be my guest
I don't know I don't know how we should
do the book maybe somebody will think of
a good idea hey if you come up with a
good idea of how to give away the book
you win the book look give it to me well
done meantime we're gonna get started
man you got a microphone there young
camper our first of the night what's
your name hey guys I'm John Joel come on
get up what is it John [ __ ] oh how did I
hear Joel everyone give it up for John
where you from John at Belfast Northern
Ireland hear my hear my Stockton there's
a little bit of an accent there man
Long Beach but Ireland sounds right too
right on man will be what your boys here
few are there over there oh [ __ ] now
this is your stag party yes my bachelor
party so we're staying in Vegas we drove
down just for tonight
and we're driving back straight after
the show congratulation when is when and
you're the one getting married yet
I get married the 26th of me of May over
in Ireland no actually in Scotland on
the Isle of Skye are you are you sure
that's cuz I'm Scottish I'm Scottish but
eleven belfast night well you can't do
that to America like one accent at a
time all right so you're Scottish
yep then you live in Belfast yep but
you're getting married in Scott yeah
okay from Vegas and you drove here well
beta it so I can have a drink okay and
your name is not Joel now how many of
those cats came from from either Belfast
all three guys from Belfast you guys
came over together flew we're together
we arrived on Sunday and we leave again
on Thursday I really like you because
that's not yeah yeah yeah I didn't pay a
penny you paid for two they put it over
I'm starting to think here that we're
getting used you're asking the question
because this is gonna be on video and
you can then prove to your wife to be
like no really we did go to a geek bar
yeah yeah we didn't [ __ ] we went there
right on and well we're honored that you
came all this way and whatnot and like
any good bachelor party me and Mark will
blow you after we're done yeah I'll
check with Mark but I think from our
crane man what what can we do you for
about to get married man you want to ask
two married men our advice run good
start with I do have a question I do
have a question related to the fact that
I'm here on my bachelor party
so far away if you could have a look
through the catalog of comic book
characters and if it was a bachelorette
party or a bachelor party who which
character would have the wildest one and
why you in the book let's unpack that
wonderful question
the idea is in ball where are we pulling
from anyone anywhere DC Marvel anywhere
star wars yeah yeah who has the best
bachelor party or best the wildest the
one that you would want to go to you
question all right let's number one not
Batman
because it would be so dour and sad so
dark oh my god he's just like why would
we celebrate being stag I lost my
parents I bet you my dad didn't have a
bachelor party I want all the strippers
to be named Martha Deadpool would be fun
Deadpool is a good boy
Deadpool will be fun but I'd be worried
I'd get killed the Deadpool he's not
he's not to be trusted
[Applause]
alright yes Tony Stark would be a good
engagement party a bachelor party to be
at although he's la me wait let's think
about Tony Stark first we said that try
thing is that a good idea or not like do
you have a good time or not which Tony
Stark we talking about Tony Stark from
Iron Man 1 yes where he's got the jet
with the stripper pole in it
yes seems like that's one go to a
bachelor party with emo Tony Stark lost
in space not a party guy no Beast Boy
Peter quill Peter quill why I think I'd
have a good [ __ ] time good music that
ship is a Jackson Pollock painting good
music if you're looking for strange that
guy has this [ __ ] spaceship that's
true we'll find you the strange
it's chawla man kill manga would have a
way better [ __ ] bachelor party I'm
trying to think here any across now all
the spectrums yeah yeah Kermit the Frog
[Applause]
you know they're eventually gonna get
married all of his friends are [ __ ]
fun like even he's got a friend who's a
comedian but I know I'm funnier than
Fozzie Bear you got [ __ ] could
play piano Ralph like you got somebody
who can like manages your dear
designated driver
scooter gonzo is [ __ ] like you know
chicks galore chickens but whatever
animal fantastic chef Syrian like crazy
pork pork pork yeah man I'm drunk from
beaker yes experiments with Ben's money
do they can probably whip up some
[ __ ] THC [ __ ] yeah man and plus a
song that we could all sing together
it's time to play the music yeah alright
I'm picking them
you got Kermit I'm taking Kermit yeah
Willy Wonka set set the table we are
gonna be balls deep in Tupelo this
little is just balls deep they don't get
higher than balls deep I don't wanna
[ __ ] a bull of what you don't know
what you're missing that my friend you
almost had me though I'm like oh we go
swimming in the Chaco River
we're gonna do all of that [ __ ] we're
gonna go on the crazy like peyote
[ __ ] bus ride I'm not gonna live [ __ ]
we're gonna be flying we're gonna
[ __ ] fizzy lifting drinks the crazy
[ __ ] up rooms that are all like small
on one side glass elevators and balls
deep into balloons yeah but at the end
of the party he's like you get nothing
good day sir and we all [ __ ] leave
which is what you won out of a [ __ ]
bachelor party I got no diseases we got
no pictures we got nothing
what happens in Wankel and stays and
walk away all right fair enough there we
go
that's what we want man and you you not
only win that but when do you head back
I have Thursday here's your tickets
here's your [ __ ] weed pipe make sure
you throw that out before you fly back
to England my best man's gonna love them
what was the third thing - we get a
shirt what size of you medium/large here
we go we got a large man it is a Kings
Dominion shirt but that's a class
there's a prize package
congrats my friend speaking as a married
man I believe in the institution it's
awesome you're gonna enjoy it
you like marriage I do like it there you
go and our wives aren't even here we
don't have to say we better than the
alternative
it's true being marrieds way better than
being alone and [ __ ] but you've got
amazing [ __ ] friends who take a ride
with you across the ocean that's [ __ ]
scotch hello hi hi ladies Angie Angie
everyone give it up for Angie so not
Halle Berry returned her name was Angie
today oh damn dude score my questions
were just talking about you being a
married man he's married he's not dead
okay yes my question is between the DC
and Marvel Universe what character would
you like to see directed what movie
character would you like to see directed
by a woman and why this great guy's a
great question give it up great question
between the DC and Marvel Universe which
character directed by woman and why me
see me see you go first
Domino I would I would totally watch it
down in a movie I would totally watch as
he beats back as Domino I think you know
she has a very cinematic superpower but
but what happens to the luckiest girl in
the world when she runs out of luck is
what that way for me would be and which
director um
[Music]
Gina price Blythe would I did love and
basketball girl is allegedly doing
silver and sable for Sony I think oh
yeah I think she's got a really good
sense of humor I think she understands
the interior life of that particular
woman in a way and I think if she's
already in the superhero movie shoot
then then that would be a pretty good
pick
[Music]
mm doesn't have to be a woman I know I
was gonna pick I'm pink I'm just trying
to figure out my director but the
project I'm picking is Sandman which
would include death so I've thought
about going like death but like you
don't just give the female character to
a female women are creative in general
that's why I always surround myself on
our sets with lots of women like they
create men don't like [ __ ] it yeah
that's why so I say that's a creative
story it needs like vast ability to tell
and to be nurtured I give that that
whole universe who would I give it to I
[Music]
don't know she's interested in directing
who Greta good a girl 180 Bert I did
like Lady Bird but is that enough to
give her Sandman let me think
Rita Moreno it's a bold choice man I'm
into that hold on let me go back to what
was my thought where was that before
somebody scream Rita Moreno yeah but who
was I thinking oh great a girl where I'm
trying that on how much did I like Lady
Bird very much it shows no remote ties
to Sandman but like you know story
challenge story tone um Kathryn Bigelow
to do Sandman I mean yeah but she's not
the first person I pick up but then
again neither is credit girl would
Michelle Maclaren yes there you go she's
done vast [ __ ] stories like on Game of
Thrones level right yeah an intimate
stuff on Breaking Bad that's right a
call so oh my god
there you go excellent choice I'm gonna
go with what he said Sandman universe
with Michelle Maclaren directly I'd
watch that buck Yeah right
I mean number one somebody's got to do
it like it's so [ __ ] imaginative and
like in a world where they just did
venom
and it made 800 million people like holy
[ __ ] who knew it's like well we all knew
because people love that [ __ ]
character same thing with Morpheus and
all those characters like it's a bunch
of fanbase just waiting for that nut to
be cracked so alright that's my choice
excellent [ __ ] question great two
answers what size are you
well medium is gonna have to do and then
you get this and then you get one of
these you get to go to the movies in a
deadly class t-shirt and smoke weed
thank you give it up for Angie to Bonnie
[Applause]
alright what's your name Erik everyone
give it up for Eric Marc I just want to
say your Nightcrawler origins book is
still one of my favorites of all time oh
thank you man that's very kind of you
and Kevin of course everything that
you've done you've actually made me the
man I am today with the very vulgar Mel
that I have so thank you why do I always
get bad for the blame I blame for the
bad laugh no it's it's like him he's
like man your work [ __ ] touches me
you taught me to say [ __ ] smoker thank
you that'll happen thank you I've I
impacted on any level that makes me
happy okay so with a lot of Directors
kind of like doing a deep dive and a lot
of studios doing deep dives how would
you put Alpha Flight into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and who would you
cast oh what a great question he's gonna
win something give it up for him that's
a great question thank you well done all
right mark you want a lead or should I
lead you you were the lover of all
things Canadian alright fair enough you
see who you're gonna pick his puck I'm
trying not to pick [ __ ] Tyrion
Lannister yeah I was gonna say you take
away from diesels Apple boxes and then
he's about the same height but he's
already crucial
that's cutting deep cutting deep alright
wait a second talk me through there
Northstar there's North sir Shaymin
Snowbird Arora Guardian sasquatch and
puck and then technically Wolverine and
currently right now I think Captain
Marvel is part of it to which Captain
Marvel Carroll really in the current
know with the comics right now
yeah she's part of it it's like a space
program right now so she's like awful
flight has it become a space program
yeah they're like we gotta get the [ __ ]
out of Canada they have her making moose
jaw's so they had to get away
oh nice all right let's think let's go
through it one by one
okay North Star you naturally alright
here we go
North Star for those who don't follow
also the first gay superhero correct
exactly so that you can't just cast
anybody like you know in a world where
Bryan Cranston got yelled at for playing
a guy in a wheelchair
you should probably cast a gay actor to
play the part so that brings us to a
specific pool of gay actors that we know
about now [ __ ] I was just gonna say
that I was gonna say Andrew Rannells
from yes Andrew Rannells gay
I believe so yes now you laughed like in
a way where you're like suck testicular
or vice versa I so Andrew Rannells guy
he's great choice I don't know that he's
the first person I think of but I loved
him in [ __ ] Book of Mormon
now now we don't know that that the case
but I would support Tom Cruise's
Northstar what a great idea
wait which is more important the the
actor should be gay but should the actor
also be Canadian that really narrows
this round
yeah Harry's right here but okay math
who said that good [ __ ] call man that
dudes offense is the dude who was in the
yeah I didn't see that what was the
movie that uh
fuck-ups the nice guys he was the bad
guy in the nice guys dudes [ __ ]
phenomenal man oh and that's right that
dude is gay all right he's our North
Star we got one we got one don't know
he's Canadian
that doesn't matter he can move yeah and
also it's like come on there has to be
some acting he has to act like he's
Canadian Canadians I mean it's and also
North American so we're all the time it
works all right
next up we've got let's go to sasquatch
CG effect probably right I would say so
so john lithgow doing the voice should
that should it be I could see that I
could see that after after watching
Orange County for like the hundredth
time yeah I can see all right CG effect
no CG effect voiced by Castle fail
Fillion Nathan because he's Canadian
he is Canadian I was gonna suggest Tim
not guys North Star but that's why right
as far as we know so he gets to play
sasquatch but be the boy not a guy in a
suit I mean that's what he kept saying
is I was second his dick all right so
[Laughter]
who do we got do next
let's do puck puck that's actually a
very good one yes Wow
as puck is a great idea man we could
just force perspective all that [ __ ]
yeah like the way they did the hobbits
and [ __ ] the old trick just let you
through the door flawed door font puck
you uh you are welcome to come work at
me and Mark studio yes
all right we have zero million dollars
in financing all right that leaves we do
guardian Snowbird Aurora Snowbird Native
American she is right anyway I believe
in you it Eskimo
are there any Eskimo actresses moon
bloodgood was a real person not just the
movie we saw yeah she was the the female
lead in Terminator Salvation yeah she
was in falling skies yeah all right we
got one we found all right so wait what
else is left
I guess Guardian another dude you're
just you're just giving the Berenstain
paper that hurt my heart man trying to
tell a story of heroes Justin Theroux
the Prime Minister of Canada themselves
amazing that's true
[Applause]
that's actually what I thought he'd been
but Justin Theroux is that actor writer
yeah no not him not him but Justin
Trudeau I would totally support that be
amazing people like don't be like the
president well not our president
president mantri gone like I'm gonna go
be in a movie like you guys I wish they
had that pool that would be very good
yeah but not you know who I mean of
course you want to say Ryan Reynolds but
he's already got a franchise a Canadian
Hero franchise Michael J Fox Wow I you
know what I we're gonna have to squeeze
some serious thetans on that dude yeah
but still worth a shot
oh wait no Jim Carrey in a dramatic turn
okay okay he played a good hero and kick
ass too yeah when he was the sergeant
star-spangled boys left that's that's I
mean we got Captain Marvel sorted yeah
so we did it we cast the movie I'm
Wolverine your Wolverine no when
hovering in the note in the in the Alpha
Flight movie our Wolverine new Wolverine
- man that was the classic choice that's
what they wanted back in the day Bob
Hoskins that was another name but it was
also I think I'm sticking with my Tom
Cruise's as Wolverine particularly in
this this movie's gonna need some had
it's gonna need some some pools just the
one American slide them in there yeah he
stopped he said he's done he hung up the
pork chop sideburns man just leave it
alone
you hung up the clothes no I would like
to see Tom Hardy in it even though I
know he's done venneman I mean it's it
was the venom movie I mean I'm with you
man though I'm like I don't get a [ __ ]
I'd see Tom Hardy do anything including
my wife
which would be really [ __ ] hot
because he'd do it in boys like I'm
coming to each overdraw hurt did you see
him at Bronson he hangs dong and Bronson
but yeah I I think that was an amazing I
mean right now maybe not for everyone
here but folks watching at home the
Canadian contingent they're like finally
somebody asked about Alpha Flight give
it up for him he asked about out my wife
they won some [ __ ] well done my friend
goddamn pleasure all right JC give us
another victim what's your name
my name is Chad Chad I won't give it up
for Chad the Chad that sure is awesome
I like your shirt Chad I'm gonna try to
find some [ __ ] big enough shirt for
the guns you're sporting right there
meanwhile what's your question take us
there I wanted to ask you about gateway
drug perks up yesterday took my
girlfriend to into the spider-verse
yes she was blown away doesn't know
anything about comic book movies comic
books any of this and in order to sink
the hook with her love for it but not
like go overboard like what our top
three things it could be a graphic
novels comic books movies TV shows what
would you say would be just the right
amount number one a great question let
me clarify though a spider-man or
anything I'd say anything anything to
get her reading comic books yeah no all
right fair enough
number one great question you're gonna
win some [ __ ] give it up for him ladies
[Applause]
hmm I will say one that we already sort
of talked about a little bit but Neil
Gaiman once described Sandman as a
sexually-transmitted comic book yeah
because dudes would read it and then
their girlfriends would read it and
they'd break up with the dudes and
they'd go meet with a new dude and then
the new do to read it and the cycle
continues but there there is something
so wonderfully human about Sandman even
though it's fundamentally missed a
physical [ __ ] which that's a word mr.
physical yes did a thing your coin and
phrases like crazy tonight it's [ __ ]
like Oxford like a [ __ ] in here um but
yeah I think that there's there's so
much that a person who's never read a
comic book can dig into because those
aren't inherently comic book stories
like it's literature like [ __ ]
Shakespeare as a character so yeah I
would I would I would recommend Sandman
for certain I would suggest and there's
based on personal experience I was
dating sort of dating this girl didn't
know anything about comic books she was
over my house and she was like you liked
these comic books
I said yes you're very observant and she
goes give me one to read I'm gonna take
a bath so I'm gonna read a comic book
give me one to read and it was like oh
my god where do I begin my one chance to
get this right like which is the book
that's gonna like [ __ ] make her not
only understand what I love about these
but that I'm worthy of [ __ ] love and
[ __ ] like that like let me show her my
[ __ ] that side of me she she was
curious enough to look into my world I
was like [ __ ] what which to lead with do
you lead with Watchmen Dark Knight
Returns is a wonderful tome but it'll
scare her away it's so [ __ ] deep and
and like götterdämmerung and stuff where
does one begin so I picked a book that
had just come out fairly recently at
that point and it was Bruce Timm and
Paul Dini did their first run at the
character of Harley Quinn a character
they created for the cartoon for the
Batman the animators first time they did
it in
DC and comic-book form was in a one-shot
called mad love there's a Baxter format
like you know bookshelf format book like
prestige for a minute that's what they
call it
so I said read this so she did and I
have a photo of that moment cuz she's in
the tub reading Mad Love sitting there
with a Burger King glass next to her a
Star Wars Burger King glass r2d2 c-3po
and there was a little Woodstock
bobblehead that's sitting over there and
her titties are floating on the water
that's why I took the picture and and I
when she got out of the tub first thing
she said was this is really good I was
like right because it's a really great
self-contained story and stuff and you
know as a female lead so for her that
that made it more interesting but then
the second thing she said was Harley
Quinn is such a great name for a kid if
we ever have a kid we should name it
Harley Quinn I was like yeah yeah you're
funny of course let's [ __ ] and we did
have the kid and we did name the kid
Harley Quinn so I recommend that book to
a complete neophyte to somebody who's
outside the medium because it worked
insanely well for her and then like led
to us having it well kid well not like
did it lead to us having a kid led to
the kid having a cool name I guess so I
got something more out of it than just a
good read and she she [ __ ] loved it
still to this day she's like that's my
favorite comic I'm like see only when
you read she's like no need to read any
more and that includes my [ __ ] I wrote
comic books after I'm like you want to
read mine she's like is as good as Mad
Love and I was like no she's like
what else a third piece uh I'm torn
between all-star Superman the Grant
Morrison Grant Morrison run and why the
last man I think I think why the last
man like if you're not about superheroes
but I feel like your girl you wanting to
get her a new supreme then all-star
Superman is like the best distillation
of that character and it's you know
there's two sort of six issue
collections of them and it's gorgeous
and it's beautiful and it's it's it is
the best of what Superman can be on the
page so yeah but she's a lady right your
your lady may be Captain Marvel bye
what's her name Kelly Kelly sue Taconic
yeah like that's the anybody who reads
comic books talks about that run and
anybody who's a woman who reads comic
books really talks about how impactful
and amazing that run is like it resulted
in us getting a movie that we're gonna
that comes out in February and stuff so
that might be the book to to be like hey
here's a book written by a woman about a
woman superhero because we keep pushing
[ __ ] like ooh there's this guy who
there's this guy but maybe you know it
might be better to lead with or Batgirl
year one which is also it was a good
book man with with the [ __ ] what was
the bad guy she beats the [ __ ] of Killer
Moth yeah that was awesome it's a
gorgeous book and it's it's it's a
really good telling of that character
Barbara Gordon's first year out yeah no
that would be great
right on thanks excellent all right you
win we're outta pipes
[Applause]
we got one more set of 10 also good for
you for bringing somebody in you know
and I'm saying like a new new blood like
that's always needed it's it's not like
meant to be this clubhouse mentality of
luck this is only for us like in a year
where a black panther gets nominated for
Best Picture
clearly this shit's for everybody and
has just been the best kept secret for
[ __ ] decades and I know there's like
temptation and some people to be like oh
man they don't understand I like [ __ ]
when it was cool
the GarageBand fan mentality but the
more the merrier man because the more
people interested in it the more
interesting things gonna come to the
field eventually like I'm not saying
like the lady that you took to the
movies is suddenly gonna [ __ ] change
comic books but that's not out of the
realm of possibility - somebody's like
oh [ __ ] I like that story I can tell a
story like that and [ __ ] boom
suddenly you have something that the
medium has never seen before fresh blood
always [ __ ] important cells the game
that's the term in hockey NHL sell the
game if you love the game you'll sell
the game and it's meant to like push it
forward convince other people like you
got to see this there's something
special here and now in the world of
this [ __ ] like we're there we're at the
point where you can bring in complete
neophytes and they'll find the wonderful
things that we've always found for years
the same [ __ ] in the material like I
envy that person who walks into that
theater and says nothing no [ __ ]
context it is about to see one of the
greatest [ __ ] superhero stories ever
told the only bad part about that is
that most [ __ ] never hits as high as
[ __ ] into the spider-verse hits but
you'll have a great time trying to find
[ __ ] that does man that's very cool all
right what is it black flash gordon
alright sure I'm in I want to see that
much money what is your name good sir my
name is Nate Nate pernais
real quick who are the socks are we
meant to sign the socks sign the socks I
don't want to presume but there's a pair
of Harley Quinn and a pair of Black
Panther which one am I supposed to sign
and which one is hark supposed to sign
[Applause]
I believe these are freezer
anyway fire away my friend sorry all
right so being a 90s baby and just to
kind of keep things on theme I'm uh one
of my favorite cartoons growing up was
Batman Beyond so well my question would
be is now that you guys kind of tossed
around the idea last episode about
making a Batman Beyond movie I think the
obvious choice for Batman would be to
bring back Michael Keaton and have him
refill the cowl if you will but if you
were to make your dream Batman movie who
would you have directed what Batman
story would you use and who would you
cast as Terry McGinnis that might three
if you wanna go for Batman Beyond yes so
it has to be in the Batman Beyond
universe yes I don't know any batman
beyond stories return of the joke well
well you can do like an actual Batman
story but apply it to the Terry McGinnis
in venom young which is like yeah it's
pretty specific run right cuz it's like
that's a version of Batman we never
really saw before Batman is mentor with
a younger Batman all right it's a wait
we're we're all taking as a given that
Michael Keaton is playing Bruce Wayne
that got a lot of [ __ ] play off the
show last week I turned on the internet
like turned on the internet like it's a
puppet
slapping the side of it why won't it
start fixing the antennas and [ __ ] once
it came on I [ __ ] saw the sudden like
Kevin Smith thinks it's a great idea to
make a Batman Beyond movie and I was
like this is not [ __ ] news
everybody thinks that would be a great
idea and [ __ ] but yeah it did get a lot
of coverage so Michael Keaton is of
course our older Bruce Wayne yes the
question is who is our Terry yeah and
what adventure do we go on yes and
number one you're definitely gonna win
this is great give it up for him you
want to talk and share it and I'll take
that sir
okay Terry McGinnis I hear I don't think
you should go with a white guy I think
here's your chance to [ __ ] be diverse
and you're not going to offend too many
people you know there's some people out
there who who is that shatter stone Oh
for like two seconds yeah
okay all right there you go there's one
I'll take that I feel like I was
thinking Michael B Jordan I mean Michael
B Jordan be amazing but I don't think
you'd get him out like I think he'd be
tough to get at this for not even his
bad name that's a good question
like that might be that might be it he
might be like look I've done black
panther and [ __ ] in terms of comic
book movies get so bigger than that and
then I've also done the Human Torch and
I [ __ ] Creed is almost a countable
character
you can't possibly impress me and then
might be like zip Batman now he could go
one of two ways he's like look yes that
is a Batman but like if I'm gonna play a
Batman I want to play Bruce Wayne I
doubt he'd be that guy I'm sure he would
see the wisdom and like oh my god you'd
be first black Batman that's a great
call who else Donald Glover I mean [ __ ]
man he was wonderful in solo I'd watch
him I'd watch him do that I don't know
they'd be my first choice he seems a
little I'm not saying he's old but he
does definitely seem a little too old to
play yeah Terry just Terry's a student
he's a high school kid right the dude
from get out Kaluga who is also in black
panther right
yeah who zendaya
you're absolutely right it don't have to
be a [ __ ] guy yeah well then does it
do they still call it Batman Beyond cuz
then it's a lady is it Batgirl beyond
its Terry with a knife beyond a man
Terry with an ax hi that's true
alright so wait who was your suggestion
zendaya
I backed that she was really good in the
spider-man movie she was really good in
that circus movie too
with you Grant those are three really
valid [ __ ] Batman Beyond they just
call the Batman on the show though yeah
they don't seem beyond nobody ever said
that out loud
yeah just us watching the show right oh
he's Batman B oh yeah is that Batman no
no no that's Batman Beyond Batman's the
old guy good all right so what adventure
would they go on and we could pull from
anywhere in the back universe any story
they've done go ahead I'm feeling Ra's
al Ghul again he's a he's immortal
it's true oh that's right there you go
Lazarus Pit his way into whatever
[ __ ] year that is ah you have me keep
going keep going that's not bad idea so
you got a villain who is immortal yes
so Bruce could be like I fought it
myself
yeah and I can't do it anymore yes it's
the it's the old Zorro model or it's
like I can't take on this guy I've got
to find the nut the young Zorro can get
on a [ __ ] horse cuz I'm too old for
horses but how what's the Bruce's like
this is supposed to be like 3040 years
after his adventures or 50 years
afterwards yeah it's like literally
right when he hangs up the cowl because
the first episode Bruce still goes out
and then he gives that whole like I'm
everything you know that's right that's
right in the pilot he was still wearing
the costume for a minute
I mean well it's number it's the first
movie and so you'd have to introduce
people to the concept of why
there's this other Batman and blah blah
blah but you know the story kind of
tells itself right up front if you do
that if you begin with oh my god could
you [ __ ] imagine like I was excited
about the notion of our fictional movie
where Michael Keaton was playing old
withered Bruce Wayne but if it begins
with Michael Keaton in a [ __ ] bat
suit I'll you can I will [ __ ] kill
myself right there anybody who's like I
hate you are that you will never have to
deal with my [ __ ] again because life
would never get better than that to see
him strap on the [ __ ] cow one more
time and not rip it off like it was made
of rubber and [ __ ] like it did in Batman
Returns remember that [ __ ] no no we
don't talk healed that [ __ ] off like a
lemon that would be amazing
that's the Batman version of the finger
snaps no the Batman version of the
finger snaps is the bat credit card.this
George Clooney pulled out that was when
you were like what happened I used to
love you so much yeah all right what
adventure did they send them on we might
have a demon I went I went into the deep
yeah you went there and I'm trying to
think I don't know I mean I'll see your
movie but I'm trying to think if I want
to make that movie Billy Dee Williams is
to face in the future
I like that that's that's good but
that's not a whole [ __ ] movie that's
like a side beat that's how it opens old
Batman is fighting old [ __ ] to face
and it's Billy Dee Williams because
they're both old and she can't do the
Dark Knight Returns yeah but I mean
that's I was thinking but you might as
well just stick to the [ __ ] pilot a
Batman Beyond but jack up the villains a
member who was the villain in the first
episode was not inked it wasn't the
Joker the Joker they didn't [ __ ] with
Felicia Joker game though yeah who's the
Joker yes chaste - Bruce Wayne Manor
and that's when he meets Bruce and
that's when he becomes like when he
stumble
the decades ben mendelsohn is the new
head of Wayne tech against Mike I gave
my story pic say again can't give you my
picture
Takia so first off i just want to stop
and say like is that what happens in the
pilot yeah yeah I mean go watch Chad
gets killed by the Joker game is that
detective
so Terry's dad Joker and then he
actually stumbles in on the crime scene
and like he sees where his dad was
killed why are you asking us what we
would do what would you do you know a
lot about this [ __ ] well first I would
place my jam when I was in the friggin
PJs in in pampers man how strange like I
mean I guess it makes sense like that
was your Batman like you know you grew
up watching that whereas we're like oh
that was a nice add jumped and we liked
that Bruce Wayne was in it but like but
for you you're like that's Batman prime
[ __ ] yeah exactly
wow that's crazy doesn't get more middle
than a black suit no the box suit is
awesome with the red with the red bat
and [ __ ] could you imagine if they just
put that out on a poster as a teaser
like summer 2021 and you just saw that
[ __ ] black the red bat you would know
what it was like anybody who knew would
know all right what's so hard about the
Arkham games when they like actually say
all right so what would you do what
you're so the comic book that really
really gripped me and even my little
sister this is the first full comic run
that we ran together was the court of
owls storyline and the two parts that
got me was one when Bruce gets wrecked
underneath the city with the court of
the city of owls or whatever yeah and
then after all the talons come and he's
in that bat suit so what I thought is
you can mix both of those parts of the
story where one you have my Michael B
Jordan Batman get lost
inside of the tunnel and so we kind of
see him spiraling into this like am I
really the Batman you know am i as good
as out here you can kind of caveat it
with where the court of owls cut their
telecom lines so they can't speak to
each other so Bruce is watching Terry
like slowly break down in the catacombs
and while this happens also in the
[ __ ] talons come knocking on the
Batcave and now not only do you get
Michael Keaton in the beginning where
he's like this old withered Batman he
also himself
in the cave fighting off all the talent
so it still shows that he's there so you
mix both of those stories and you get to
Batman's for the price of one in Rock
yeah dear Warner Brothers you should
talk to me that that is [ __ ]
phenomenal man that is definitely a
movie I would [ __ ] pay cash money to
see multiple times why aren't you
charged of [ __ ] I mean I'll join you
guys a studio you guys have 0 millions
to throw around
we don't yeah I know our studio [ __ ]
sucks man holy [ __ ] that takes so many
boxes like you know who would also enjoy
that movie the same people that go see
Clint Eastwood movies like Opie will
they'll be like you mean an old man is
gonna home alone the Batcave you know
I'm going for a discount show like
they'll [ __ ] come out for that that
that captures a lot of imagination young
and old
well done man give it up for them
weren't asking just for that not only do
you get the screen X passes and a deadly
class shirt you get the fat ass deadly
class Kings Dominion hoodie sweatshirt
affair my friend well done
[Applause]
God that was [ __ ] satisfying I know
I'm spent
it is sometimes it's more fun to come to
this show and hear people's ideas about
what movies could be than it is to
actually go see some of the movies like
that that's that's legit wonderful flick
and I'll be driving at home thinking
about that and then sooner or later I'll
remember it's not real and I'll be like
what a horrible world we live in I think
we've covered everything man we did the
[ __ ] news we told you some [ __ ] up
front we've we've done the QA this I
take home is this for me yes taking this
as well with these bags are these meant
for me and Mark to take what's the story
there
they're vegan cookies if I love and blow
them up yes they're called Madeline's
Maxine's Maxine's heavenly note there
they are I am NOT a vegan I am a proud
meat-eater but you are vegan and they're
amazing there you can find them in Whole
Foods and they're just great just try
them you will love them I'm down thank
you so much focus we give it up she
brought us snacks
now what's what's happening what is yeah
what's the story with these two things
here who knows that come over here and
so we could see you and JC we'll give
you a mic and this look to her Nate
what's your name RAF RAF yeah everyone
give it up for RAF so there was a
podcast a few months ago where you asked
mark what movie prop what he won and it
was the golden idol so I was in my
studio working and I'd like left out of
my seat because that was something I was
crafting that is but it's not the golden
island it is uh it a friend of mine Adam
Rosalind he made a mash up of Biggie and
MODOK and I back when Facebook was fun I
saw this and I was like oh I have to
make this and I put in my little folder
to make so I sculpted it digitally and
then I released it everybody's like oh
my god it's amazing you should print it
up and it's like yeah Big E as MODOK yes
that's [ __ ] genius Hey it was there I
just made it into the sculpture and I
got like a jkirby head absolutely
[ __ ] gorgeous man's and actually that
gold people that fabricated the copy of
the idol they did that to calm the sick
mode
what is like what if somebody's sitting
you know they're [ __ ] MODOK fans and
who also probably happened to be a
biggie fans if they're looking at us
going like why them why not me it can be
them but you guys don't have any shows
scheduled for February and the
Kickstarter is supposed to go live in
February and this was the last show so I
was like [ __ ] gotta go ahead and just
oh wait explain how is it's not working
it will eventually be on sale but it's
gonna kick starter campaign doesn't
start until yes I start till February
yes well that still gives us a chance so
what so it's happening after this it's
gonna go live February 11th February
11th all right so look at this what the
[ __ ] you don't want this [ __ ] you this
is the greatest thing in the world where
can they find you it's a weird name it's
at Djibouti Sanjay eh uty s am on
Instagram and Twitter but I had a friend
also do artwork based off of everything
that was like biggie MODOK and then the
final piece so he is really kind of a
genius yeah he is that's the biggie
yeah yeah and I have a bunch of artists
Saturday I'm not gonna know this is the
bow doc yes and what are you guys gonna
be doing with the Kickstarter make sure
yeah and then funding the next one which
is kind of close to the chest at the
moment but I have oh I was gonna do
another piece
yeah it's mmm 85% done so yeah all right
so the it'll begin in February February
11th what do you know you're gonna list
it under is a biggie MODOK or somewhat
aureus MODOK the notorious MODOK yes no
all right so you've seen it now if
you're into it man you go to where at
djibouti's on je h UT y si n on Twitter
and Instagram it's a terrible name but
yeah where are you doing the kiss
kickstart it's gonna be through
Kickstarter I'm shooting the campaign
video this weekend so so when it's
mid-february
go to Kickstarter and look for notorious
MODOK
that's engine that's [ __ ] dope man
give it up for us a beautiful piece
[Applause]
shoulda gave him the book
quid pro quo that's that's I think we've
covered all the show we got ladies and
gentlemen have you had a good time this
evening I cannot thank you enough for
coming out man but there is no show
without the smart one give it up for the
guy to my right mr. Marc Bernardo and
that is fat man on beyond for this week
I'm Kevin Smith I am mark Renard tune in
next week same time same fat channel
SModcast calm or youtube.com slash Kevin
Smith go beyond ladies and gentlemen
good eye
[Applause]
you